everyone and welcome to today's webinar
optimizing high content screening tools
for physiologically relevant 3d in vitro
models
Michell action of labyrinth and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labyrinth and brought to you by
molecular devices to learn more please
visit www.opm.gov/life to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send for answers many questions of the
epstein-barr at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top-right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and best offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit
I now present today's speakers dan
oconnor North America bioimaging
director molecular devices ality van der
hot study director at HCS Pharma
and the ado here is senior scientist HCS
Pharma
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the browser fee tab at the
top of your screen our speakers will now
begin their presentations
thanks Michelle hi this is dan oconnor
I'm the North American director for bio
imaging with molecular devices
I'll be talking about overcoming
challenges in automated high-throughput
3d imaging using high con some imaging
there's a variety of 3d applications
ranging from zebrafish night outgrowths
organized the elegans
Basava
3d whole slide imaging and spheroids to
name a few we'll be going through each
of these applications and how we can
overcome challenges with solutions of
Imaging
here's a typical 3d cell culture
steps for creating bioimaging assays in
3d as you can see on the left the
culture of steroids
with compound stain for markers
acquire 3d cell image
analyze with your hike on
Imaging software
they will be talking strictly about
these last four requiring 3d cell images
and analyzing
there are some challenges that you will
encounter with high-throughput 3d
imaging I have listed five of the top
challenges that I believe are creating
issues with with large 3d imaging assays
Imaging creates undesirable autofocus or
hazy images that could skew image
analysis
six samples have difficulties with light
penetrating through the entire tissue
reliable automated focusing on 3d plate
types such as organ on the chip a new
bottom plate actives acquisition time is
long when you have to do multiple fields
of view and D stacking
data sets are large and complex large
data sets can take hours to analyze
becoming a bottleneck exporting data to
3d imaging software can be tedious
cumbersome and inconsistent stand-alone
3d imaging software is not designed for
multi well multi played data
visualization in high constant data
mining
first challenge 3d imaging grids and the
undesirable out-of-focus or hazy images
that can skew image analysis you can see
on the left
have a wide field image and a confocal
image the confocal image cleans up that
haze our autofocus part of the image
very well
on the right you see the analysis and in
confocal we count over 30% more of the
nuclear making it a much more accurate
qualification with console confocal
we have two solutions with market
advices to tackle this
if you have a wide field system have a
on-the-fly 2d deconvolution that allows
his cleanup
you can do this 2d deconvolution
or digital console in both wide field
and confocal
we also have a hardware solution
that is a spinning disk confocal
technology that is optimized for high
resolution issue penetrance and high
throughput
we have recently launched
high-performance customizations on the I
am cut bocal that includes high
intensity lasers auto dispensing water
immersion objectives and a proprietary
confocal disc module for decreased
pinhole crosstalk and increased tissue
penetrance
as you can see in this slide we lay out
the optical path of the I exon confocal
with these new high performance
customizations it is now optimized for
automated high-throughput 3d imaging
assays with our water immersion
objectives 20 40 and 60 X that reduces
light refraction for brighter intensity
at lower exposure times
also have the deep tissue penetrating
comic book of this module
that allows greater depth into tissue
and reduces crosstalk to improve auto
focus light suppression
this consult of this module has a low
light transmittance
we make up with high intensity lasers
for five or eight channels
these lasers are 1,000 milliwatts per
channel
offer busting class
light excitation
positions light penetrants into 30
samples we just discussed the
confocal disc module that increases
light penetrates into sick tissues with
specialized disc geometry designed for
reintroducing pinhole crosstalk and
autofocus light suppression
this image you can see with a 60 micron
pinhole confocal spinning disc
versus the deep tissue confocal disc
module
another challenge is reliable automated
focusing on 3d play types such as
organized chip a new bottom
our solution is to have a robust high
speed laser and image out of focus this
allows you to consistently and reliably
focus on each wrong bottom plate in 96
wells for 384 wells
on the right you see our laser autofocus
and our software autofocus mechanisms
feature here is that the the system
finds the plate bottom that's that plate
bottom thickness
then finds the well bottom and sets that
offset
this allows for a very robust laser
autofocus amount of focus focus
mechanism
third challenge is played opposition
time is long compared to 2d
in a well plate you will have your
objects of interest scattered throughout
the well
the only way to capture each of these
objects is to scan the entire well as
you can see if with this grid overlay
our solution is to do a quick ID
targeted imaging
if the system will automatically find XY
positions of objects of interest with a
low magnification
automatically switch to a high
magnification such as 40 X in this case
and go to those points of interest and
the objects are always in the center of
the region of interest
this allows for faster acquisition
Plus image storage had less images to
analyze
so the last challenge here is datasets
are large and complex
again lit large datasets can take hours
to analyze becoming a bottleneck and
exporting data to a 3d imaging software
could be tedious a standalone 3d imaging
software is not designed for multi-well
also played data visualization
solution is to have an integrated 3d
analysis with single interface reducing
time to discovery
we can now quantify 3d structures with
volume intensity and this is distance
measurements all with one interface and
then software
a couple of snapshots with our 3d image
analysis these algorithms algorithms
identify cells and organize and detect
volumes
images were captured with a 10x plan at
0.45 numerical aperture objective in 16
micron pinhole confocal with Z stack of
23 D plans at 10 micron steps
these objects of interest were about 250
microns you can see in the software can
automatically identify each cell at each
different Z plane
this allows the software did not count
the cell more than once
so detect volumes in the bottom right
picture
here's a 3d viewer to visualize XYZ
co-localization and organize volumes Oh
play a quick video that shows the
features of the 3d viewer software
you
we also lay out another challenge of
data sets are large and complex
take hours to become and become a
bottleneck
our solution is to accelerate analysis
speeds by up to 40 X with multi-threaded
parallel processing with our mad Express
power core software we can now go from
hours to minutes
eliminating 3d analysis as your
bottleneck you can also run multiple
image express systems in parallel
as you can see we utilize the Intel
processors for multi-threaded parallel
processing
to continue the challenge of data sets
our large and complex we also attack
this by having a integrated solution for
bioinformatics called acute Express this
allows for 3d phenotypic data mining and
visualization we can do plots
self-organizing maps
for component analysis
/ fitting all automatically with the
touch of a button
we have additional resources such as
ebooks and our new 3d web page that I
encourage you to click and explore
our 3d ebooks are a great resource for
all the informations that we covered in
this webinar
next up we have HCS Pharma which is a
wonderful partner of molecular devices
they are a new technology 3d application
technology driver that has CRO services
that can maximize the rent ability of
their of your studies by enabling more
parameter extractions in less time they
will go through their technology in more
detail
thank you
thank you Dan for the introduction
so I'm Elodie I'm working in a shed for
my company and I'm here today with year
two gear to our expert in biomaterials
who is also the inventor of biome images
technology that we will detail later on
I'm working at the study director and I
will talk to you about HDS farmer and
the biological results link to
biomedical technology so in this second
part we will we will tell you how to
create physiologically relevant 3d in
vitro models for the screening of
molecules using bio mimesis
so HGS Pharma is a company localized in
France in Lille more precisely we
equipped with two fully we were equipped
with two essential apps one automation
and cell imaging lab that you can see on
this picture and one projection chemical
lab for the creation of biomimicry
states
we also equipped with with robots in
standalone and we will talk to you more
detail about the to image Express
microcon focus system that we have
integrated on the platform we provide
services in safety and efficacy estates
in measurement i throughput we also
provide you services link to cell assay
development proof of concept and
mechanism of action as well as
consulting in pharmacology cosmetology
and nutria septic cells and also now you
know we are selling also products by the
mini displays that we also are using
in-house for a 3d cell culture studies
on on this slide so you can see
different pictures of the platform that
was designed and integrated by molecular
devices for different views you can see
the twin magic squares microcontroller
systems that we have one on the left are
being terminated for lifestyle imaging
one robotic arm taking the plate from
one device to another one pippity system
on the Left 496 and 384 well placed from
CEO three different incubators one plate
chiller and also one plate for sure so
everything is integrated on this
platform that we are using for studies
screening of condoms for example for the
pharmaceutical industry
so we just want to introduce you a
little bit about the high failure rate
in drug discovery because as you know
90% you may know 90% of drugs fail and
very late stage meaning in clinical
trials in particular in Phase two
clinical trials and this is due to lack
of efficacy and we think that this lack
of the key efficacy in the clinical
trials is due to a lack of relevant in
vitro models human individual models in
the preclinical stages
in fact most of the of the screenings in
the early stages of drug discovery are
performed on 3d cell purchase meaningful
cells grown on plastics as monolayers
most of the time the point is that they
differentiate within few days while in
reality the cells are grown in a complex
environment different cell types are
together they are all embedded in
extracellular matrix and they are also
blood vessels which is objecting that
the case in 3d that's why we really
think that we should go further into in
3d cell circuit remodels and that's why
we are using biome images for indeed for
in vitro studies so our point of view is
that we should reproduce 3d cell culture
everybody's many cells and with the ECM
meaning the extracellular matrix with
the appropriate physical physical
chemical properties and that's why we
are using bio images now I I will let
Viet talking about this technology in
more detail
thank you LG to introduce biome images
ticker technology and the other value of
our technology we have to present the
existing technology and with their
advantages and limitation the first
class are the scaffold the free model is
based on the formation of Manas fluid
using external stress by the
modification of the form and surface
treatment for Europe plate or gravity
for ranking a drop and using metallic
nanoparticles for magnetization the
adventures of the technologies are the
edge tools and their adaptability force
clinic but the lack of specific micro
environment is a major limit and
disadvantage in this system
for the classification of the secondo
class based on a matrix as a support for
sacred sure we will focus and the nature
and the physical chemical properties of
different models well find the classic
system based on hydrogel for example
thermo sensitive hydrogel as a matron
gel and all the hydrogel based on
biopolymer or synthetic polymer among
the advantages of this system are their
cost and the adaptability for clinic but
they need of preparation before use and
the bed diffusion of growth factor and
or oxygen due to the encapsulation of
cells added the model are oncogenic
or no physiologic micro environment are
the major limitation of the system
desiccant carried our sewage cavort
based on synthetic plastic like polymer
as polystyrene and other polymer the
systems present a cost and ready to use
advantage the limitation of the system
are the absence of specific cell metrics
and direction and the difficulty of the
use in a magic system the third class is
the draw Idris cathode model and for us
I discovered our 3d system combining
hydrogel and solid cathode behaviour and
we consider this arised organ or tissue
as I discovered
the system presents real physiologic
micro environment but I'd cost there
poor predictability and the difficulty
of they use in screening and imaging
system are the main limitation to
overcome to overcome all the limitation
of this last model where proper solution
is a solution with our technology
biomimetic hydro scaffold and the
technology ready to use was a
cost-effective usable and screening and
with a good rapport with a
predictability and first circuit system
and bio MEMS it was developed to better
mimic the ICF but what what we need to
do we did to reproduce ICL today all
scientists agree the role is the
important role of the ACM in to maintain
the structure of tissue and to define
the cell micro environment and the SEM
is a key determinant for of server and
function and so the ECM composition is
tissue specific indeed for each organ or
tissue we found the main compounds with
different amount the ECM are composed
generally by glycans I mean I mean I
mean applicants like uric acid
our structural proteins or adhesion
proteins like collagen or fiber linking
or laminate
the role the role and the and hanukkah
c2h a as a symmetrical functions in ECM
to maintain the structure and as a
reservoir for water underground fact and
growth factors and receptors
and specific characteristic of each ECM
is the mechanical probability all the
elastic modulus that define the
stiffness or elasticity of ECM
for AC or pathologic organ and the
composition and the rigidity of the ECM
or Azul and the cutter of of the organ
pathologic or or LC organ and to
reproduce the ECM we need to know the
composition and the mechanical
properties and now our
to explain how we developed by my
memories is carried out by cross-linking
reaction of Eric acid with collagen 1 4
& 6 using idea as cross linker to obtain
the at first a nitrogen but the hydrogen
is not suitable for cell culture due to
the first degradation and the innovation
in a shiozawa we have developed a new
process to improve the mechanical
propriety of images and 2 throws for
hydro gel to I discovered and we see in
the picture the same same composition of
comparison in vivo system with the
desire eyes organ and and just to
explain why by me me this is I draw
scaffold when you when you added medium
to by religious driver scaffolds well
and presence in medium and when we zoom
we observe under microscopy the presence
of fiber and a translucent due to
presence of either yes and then we have
the to behavior of like sewage scaffold
and hydro gel and now biome image is
either scaffold biome images is is
marketed in in precast matrix in 96 well
plate with different format plate and
amount and we can modify the thickness
of the matrix for over our life for I
discovered for our application imaging
or another and today's is the Israeli to
use only technology based on ionic acid
and ACM compounds purpose and the market
the rabbit for a for project aspired by
a Paragon diamond is brain by remedies
lever and by Matisse adipose tissue and
by pathology whereby magician collegiate
use for different stage of concern and
now I let the elegy result some proof of
concept result with binary search
technology thank you yet so I will take
over and first with by enemy deceiver
this matrix is composed of hyaluronic
acid granted with a GDS ID in peptide
collected on II collagen one when
collagen for with an elastic modulus of
0.6 kilopascal
this matrix has already been validated
for the culture of cell lines a critical
line and a party cell lines
it has also been used for the culture of
primary Germany but aside and last but
not least this matrix has also been used
for the differentiation of induced
pluripotent stem cells into major a
battle site
I will show you a couple of results
first with biomimetics liver and primary
human tabata site as you can see on the
electron microscopy pictures the matrix
by itself is close in its in its
structure to the DC revised liver
extract ela matrix you can see the
yellow unique shapes and interlace the
fibers of collagens on the right you can
observe primary Germany battle sites
that have the form of farad within the
matrix we have characterized the cells
in these conditions and compared it to
3d culture in collagen one sandwich
condition the interesting thing is that
albumin secretion is much higher when
the stars are cultivated in biome images
liver and this higher production of
vibrantly is maintained over time we
have statistic until twenty eight
thousand and one month and again the
activity the ship activities have been
quantified and simply a for for example
is its activity is doubled in biome
images compared to 3d ship 1 a1 one a2
activity is is multiplied by 3 + 56 you
have more than 8 fold increase between
2d and 3d for the basal activity of
opposite so this this shows that a
pesticide grown in bio-memory civil
maintained in functionality for I mean
at least one month and suggests that
they are close to the in vivo situation
as his closer than 2d culture
FG - Celina has been cultivated in biome
images for the study of the cool
aesthetic effect of compounds
chlorpromazine is a compound that can
induce the stabilization of biliary
canaliculi which is known as the
cholestatic effect you have the X aim of
this farad's together with the green
staining of Ag FDA which is substrate
for this bio rican alkali and you can
see with the increased concentration
Popham a sign that you have a
destabilization in the structure of the
after of the canaliculi and this could
even be quantified using a meta Express
granularity application module so you
can see the graph on the on the right
that is quantifying the effect the token
a static effect of chlorpromazine
moreover a party party Selene has been
cultivated in in by many deceivers who
check for the post chaotic effect the
statuses is the increased accumulation
of lipids and again this is a parameter
that you can easily analyze analyze with
image analysis using ID provide the
staining for example we have tested
different compounds as you can see on
this table that are known to induce
stategies or not and we compared to the
condition with steroids obtained with
ultra low attachment place and with by
religious culture in 3d and compared in
fact the responses and induced are to
this chaotic effect as you can see on
the table the 3d all the other compounds
I've shown post at which it affects with
a at least double most of the time a
double increase in the accumulation of
lipids with all our plates you still
have this high increase in the in the
drink accumulation of lipids but even if
there is a little shift in the
concentrations and with biome images you
have a new observed less impact of the
of the compounds on the accumulation of
your piece on the steer to this effect
again when we could see this effect it
was with higher concentrations much
higher concentrations and even for the
two last compounds with genuine and me
to accept no effect could be observed so
this seems that there is lower status
effect on the cells environment River
the cell survival was better in these
conditions so what we could conclude is
that in 3d it can give warnings
according to the toxicity or safety of
molecules but it's not predictive of
what's happening in in human beings
because all these drugs are taken by us
because they are approved medicine so by
me
this seems more predictive in in the in
the human effect
I I will I will talk to you about the
doctrine session of IPs feeds into a
parasites in Bali limited heaver
if this is a collaboration with a
statute or acts in not his PhD students
was done this work we have compared the
differentiation into G versus the
differentiation in a limited in 3d and
I've done a extensive agonistic study
tool to check the expression of genes
you have all the examples here of genes
that have been up regulated in 3d and
they are just with file metabolism fatty
acid metabolism cholesterol lipoprotein
glucose insulin cytochrome is vision of
yogic related metabolism which is a
great interest it shows that the cells
are major and we have characterized the
spirits that we have obtained in this
condition and this organ which contains
obviously about resides so you can see
on the picture in thanks to the Aibileen
staining in green but very interestingly
we also know that there are some other
cells likes tell itself as you can see
with the red staining and also under
seal yourself
this was also suggested by the agonistic
study because we knew that some genes
were not from hypothesized so we have
complete organ with obtained from this
differentiation and we are now
characterizing the storage in terms of
sleep activity for example and
metabolism I just give an example here
with CPA for and sip 29 that we see are
active in industries all these results
suggest that the differentiation of EPS
seeds into a parasite is is great in
these conditions and so our studies are
ongoing and in English field
I remember to valium in this adipose
tissue bio-memory this adipose tissue is
composed of the alumina Kassadin LGDs
adhesion peptide and collagen one and
sticks its elastic modulus is of point
forty five kilo pascal and this matrix
has already been validated for the
culture of primary human adipose ice for
of cell lines that can be differentiated
into adipocytes and our collaborators
I've also used it for the
differentiation of IPS sieve into major
human adipose eyes I will show you a
couple of with us but if you need more
information and just be aware that the
publication was was done by do we in
2017 in biotechnology and bio and
genuine Journal
again the structure of biome images
adipose tissue is really close to the in
vivo de Sciglio right human adipose
tissue extracellular matrix as you can
see on these pictures interestingly the
cells are organized Isis ferrets as
waves here I'd be 14 and I seen by exxon
microscopy which looks like the
structure that you can also observe in
vivo and on the right the images show
you dis favorite within biome images and
the staining by a Depot head but shown
here in in green shows an accumulation a
normal accumulation of lipids or
frivolity right more particularly within
this within the spirit of adipocytes
which is what we can expect from such
self we also compared this condition
with 2d conditions and again you you can
see on the on this graph that there is a
higher accumulation of the traditions in
the in the cells within biome images
again this differentiation is maintained
for at least one month in 2d you can see
from the picture that is really
difficult to maintain a complete culture
expressing and showing good accumulation
of lipids and like in 3d on the right in
biome images also some genes have been
validated as a differentiation markers
but I won't show show them here you
might have more information in the
publication if if needed
just for your information biome images
adipose tissue has also been
successfully successfully tested for the
culture of cyber sites in particular
human IPSC daresay besides this is a
collaboration that we have within a cell
thanks to this picture you can see that
the several sites also accumulate a
little bit a scene injury and on the
right they also Express look one as a
sign of good differentiation within
biome images so this shows that the
cells are can be also maintained at
least for one month in these pictures
were taken at the 28th after seeding
I'm done with buying images adipose
tissue so I will move to biome images on
ecology so the the commercial matrix is
composed of organic acid and collagen
one with an elastic modulus of 0.8
kilopascal and I mrs. oncology has been
validated for the culture of cancer cell
lines in general I mean other one cells
and also for the culture of cancer cells
from patients I will show you some
results about drug testing in biome
images oncology here you
HT 29 cells with life that
and that cells are red we tested
different concentration of the
anti-cancer drug side through c5 f you
and we thanks to imaging we could put we
could design the 50 curves and we can
see from the blood that the Whizzer
shift in this APC 50 curves between 3d
and 3d environment is suggesting again
that the responses are closer to in vivo
situation in terms of responsive to
drugs so this this type of study is done
on all the cell types and as other
screenings are ongoing and now I will
present you and the results regarding
how we can play around with the matrix
and with composition and physical
properties because it's something that
can be done and I would buy all images
but not necessarily necessarily with
other types of systems here we played
with the elastic modulus of bio images
and checked the culture and the growth
of
HTT a 116 cells within few days you can
see the extending of the cervix in the
Mattocks and interestingly we could
observe that the increased elastic
modulus i will increase collagen one is
linked to higher cell proliferation and
in bio images so this also can be linked
to what has already been described in in
other studies and also in vivo regarding
the impact of the physical properties of
the matrix on the self alliteration and
and the impact of mechanical stress on
the south we have played around again
with composition and stiffness of the
matrix but this time by preaching
laminin into the matrix here is a study
performed on the breast cancer cells
mgmg 231 we've stained
X and the calcium green meaning the
living and proliferating cells are in
green and we have checked the the
evolution of the area of the spirits
meaning the growth of the cells a long
time for one month and here you have
again an impact of the elastic modulus
but importantly in the presence of
laminin we were decreasing in fact the
cell growth contrary to what my boobs
are before just the presence of laminin
had an impact a negative impact on the
growth of the steroid of the time so
this is quite interesting and again
which is in line with what has already
been seen in other studies and is also
interestingly the expression of cd44 was
checked again a long time to d44 here
which is seen in in in red and the the
composition and stiffness of the magic
seems not to have any impact of the unde
expression of cd44 just in all
conditions it seems to whoever increased
a long time so the matrix stiffness and
the presence of laminin has no impact on
the expression of obvious marker
you
I would like to finish with a biome
images on ecology by telling you that
even it can also be used in vivo thanks
to its properties because it is solid it
can be easily be grafted in life and it
was compared to a classical injection of
cancer cells in mice and the the
grafting was much higher as much
successful we buy remedies with 100%
success compared to 63 percent success
in just with the injection of cancer
cells so it can also be news Aviva with
good
engraftment of the cells within the
surrounding tissues
the last matrix I represented by images
brain
this one is composed of yellow ionic
acid courage and for lggs addition
peptide and catching it by your polymers
the elastic modulus is quite low it's
0.1 kilopascal to tube in line with the
with the in vivo the fact that the brain
is is really smooth this matrix has been
validated for the culture of different
cells accents immortalized human
dopaminergic new neuronal precursor
cells which can be differentiated into
major dopaminergic neurons but also for
SH s y5 one cells in service and also
for the culture of human family at
suicide but this is one of our last
matrix matrices so we are still
characterizing this so other validations
will come shortly for example with
family human endurance
so different cell types like Loomis
cells can be grown in by your images for
again one month as you can see on this
picture with x10 bittersweet tubulin
staining obviously new methods cannot be
cultivated for so long in 3d and primary
human ostracized as you can see with the
green staining in green green staining
sorry you can maintain again primary
human as besides for one month
we checked again are the impact of drugs
on the on Loomis tells this time
environment is brain and the impact of
MPP class and elastin that are known as
Parkinson disease in juicers in
particular a resting is responsible for
a specific type of cell death
therapeutics and we compared to D and
spherical shine biome images we tested
them are different concentrations to
grow the the curves for the impact on
cell death and there is a little shift
in the curve with amity + suggesting
that the higher concentration should
should be achieved to a true induce cell
death in biome images and more
importantly regarding arresting we had
difficulty to see the the high cytotoxic
effect of Ariston at the tested
concentrations because into the less
than one micromolar is necessary to to
kill all the cells and you we could not
observe any cytotoxic effect at the
tested concentration within by images so
it seemed that we have a lower
sensitivity of the cells in volume
images and we are going on with
investigations to know why and what's
the mechanism behind
um I will finish with Vienna missus
types of plates because now when we have
biome images in 384 Wednesday's which is
very convenient for high-throughput
screening studies we have great
reproducibility between plates and also
within one plate regarding the 3d cell
cultures shift in these conditions
so screening is currently ongoing with
biome images oncology to to check the
effect of anti-cancer drugs and to maybe
find the new drugs in in libraries so
this is a good means that by music is
available for live screenings of of
molecules
I just finished just with a few words on
3d cell culture also because obviously
if you are using cells in 3d we need to
make the proper a picture acquisition
which is possible with our metics faster
macro confocal system and then we need
to reconstruct the disparage that we get
or the stretch structures that we can
observe in 3d before extracting
interesting parameters and interpreting
the biological results and this is what
can be achieved with the 3d analysis
module of estimate Xpress so in the
software and there is a 3d analysis
custom module and for example a fine
spherical object algorithm is very
efficient so I will send you the video
so as you can see on this video you can
easily in fact image discourage this
stir it was not obtained in bio music
because it is unique so it it was in
good hollow attachment place you can see
the nuclei of the cells and you can
check and then numbers you can check the
size of the of the spirits you can also
do analysis of volume so thanks to this
module
and I will finish on how what to
remember about Bahama missus technology
so by images technology is the only
ready to use Idris capsules composed of
the ironic acid and other ECM components
on the market it is natural and
physiological because yelenic
acid is under its physiological form and
you are in presence of under natural
rated collagens this matrix is scalable
in versatile you can have it in
different formats it is compatible with
most if not all common downstream
analysis techniques even if I have been
given more details but just know that
you can do peace yours you can take the
cells for flow cytometry after culture
etc primary cells maintain the phenotype
longer in biome images first lowing
long-term experiments
I mean connect with treatments are
allowed and by images can also be used
in vivo as well
don't edit it to take our website for
more information or to send any other
question to to our e-mail LOH images
come so I would like to thank you for
your attention and before going to your
questions we would like to thank diem
frigate and strategic plan for molecular
devices for our collaboration with them
and to sell a piper for organizing this
webinar thank you thank you
you
Thank You Ella TZ ed and Dan for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live Q&A portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for okay first question is
see
okay it looks like we may have answered
this in the presentation but just to
recap do you already have you already
developed the biome NZ's community for
well plate
yes
so by minutes has been developed also in
unit format so if you need such such
format you can you can already yeah
great thank you great okay
next question what do you mean by it can
be applied
sorry once one moment what do you mean
by it can be applied to in vivo we just
mean that it can be used for grafting
knife I mean you can sit cells within
the mattresses and just take the matrix
it's it's solid you can put it and graft
it in mice and this has already been
done with a collaborator so this is the
way I wanted to say when when I said you
can use it in vivo so for for example
cancer cell grafting I hope it's clear
but yeah
great thank you all right next question
how have you done your fixation and
permeabilization before your I F so it
depends on the protocol but most of the
time you we are using most of the time
formally for fixation and for the
feminization we use either twin or pitot
tweet-tweet on if it's a 100 so you can
use both depending on on your on your on
your staining and and even I guess
others because the matrix is quite
stable in such classical protocols I
would say so
Thank You Ellie all right next question
how many cell images can catch from 3/8
or four well for imaging analysis
I'm so um yeah I'm sorry uh go ahead
Audie okay no no no it's it's your
question no problem
yeah okay I yeah I was curious because
it was the the question I was not
exactly sure on what what is being asked
but how many cell images can catch per
384-well plate crank the if we do we can
have several different objectives if we
have a low magnification objective for
example a 4x objective on our systems we
can capture the entire well so you can
take 384 images per very well or you can
go all the way up to a hundred X
magnification which would then be about
100 images for a while and in that case
I'd be about 38,000 images per 384 well
plate
answer that correctly I was a little
confused on the exact intent of the
answer or question
great thank you Dan okay next question
let's see while we're getting so many
great questions okay what is the cost
for a 96-well plate
so there is difference between the
different matrices in terms of
composition but it's around
between 200 300 and 300 euros per plate
so but obviously okay since we can also
do customized matrices we can also do
specific quotations for very specific
matrices but it's run 250 300 euros per
page
great thank you okay next question is
there any development by oMG for muscle
cells
we have we have some some collaborator
is tri smooth muscle cells but but at
the moment we are going to result
you
thank you all right next question
see
okay next question
have you made fixation and permutation
of 3ds steroids
we I'm I
it was the same fixation in
thermalization I've just talked about
I'm family for defecation and hit one
out will for paralyzation for most of
the of the for most of their images yeah
thank you okay the imaging of 3d
fairways showed nuclei only around the
outside of the sphere have you used any
techniques to more fully capture the
inside of the spheroid such as clearing
like I think I can answer this so yes
we've definitely used techniques for
tissue clearing in fact it's a great way
to see deeper into tissue there's
several different tissue clearing
methods out there we have worked with
physical in the past but but yes is a
great way for seeing clearly into
thicker 3d organized
great thank you how do you manage the
imaging system
I can answer that as well I believe this
is in reference to baby i qo q or GXP
environment zr imagers don't have an
actual g XP or IQ oq however we have
several customers that we can customize
and lock down certain features for
auditing purposes and CFR part 11
compliance e state thank you
alright it looks like we have time for
one more question if this one is for
Ella T did have you ever worked with
smooth muscle cells in your matrixes
I think we have answered already to this
question we find that from we haven't
here and here in the lab worked with
smooth muscle cells but some
collaborators I've done so we cannot
give you the results or how it worked
but I mean there's no reason why
synthesis is not going in in in line by
images but we haven't tried here
great thank you and it looks like we
have a request for publications and we
will follow up with your question after
the webinar is finished so thank you for
that one thank you again
Elodie Zed and Dan for your time today
and your important research we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor molecular devices for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their questions any questions we did not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speakers via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on-demand laborat will alert you
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye